the scientists and philosophers like to
think that they're very sober rational
people who are above the need to
advertise and yet if you look closely
you'll see that they often go to great
lengths to come up with a vivid
memorable term a label for their theory
or a name for it
that will stick in people's heads there
in other words they're trying to develop
a brand name or advertising or trademark
for their view and we should recognize
that's a good thing to do if you're
going to run an example or if you're
gonna run an argument try to make it as
easy as possible for the audience or the
reader to keep track of the elements
don't call them a B C D and E call them
Bill and Arthur and Freddie and and so
forth but of course that could backfire
on you too or it can be misused one of
my favorite bad
thought experiments bad intuition pumps
is one in a very influential paper by
Greene and Cohen published in the
Proceedings of the Royal Society on what
neuroscience tells us about free will
and this is the boys from Brazil and in
this thought experiment where to imagine
this it's inspired by the hokey science
fiction film the boys from Brazil about
some evil doctors who who clone Hitler
and they're trying to make Hitler clones
and but in in this telling they create a
human being who's been designed by their
evil intentions to live a life of crime
to do evil things but just as rational
as anybody else he's very much
controlled he's sort of a sort of a
designed psychopath
and they call him mr. puppet and they
describe mr. puppet and mr. puppet goes
out and commits a crime and they appeal
to the readers that to conclude that mr.
puppet isn't really responsible for his
for his evil deeds he shouldn't be
punished certainly yeah he's just the
victim of his circumstances
and then bless them they say now Daniel
Dennett might object that this is just
an intuition pumping that we shouldn't
take it seriously yes it's not that it's
an intuition pump the intuition pumps
could be good it's a it's a bad
intuition pump and they say they just
having noticed having imagined that I
might be critical of their intuition
pump they go ahead and do it anyway so
let me now turn the knobs on this
intuition pump and we'll see what we can
make of it first they say the fact that
this this person was created by evil
scientists with evil intent that's
irrelevant to the example really so all
right so let's get rid of them we'll
turn that in the haben so and in
different environment produces a human
being who they say by design is set out
on uh sort of anti-social trajectory
well but we can get rid of that by
design too because if it's an
indifferent environment then there's no
intent on this so we now we've got this
an indifferent environment happens to
produce an individual who with high
probability will engage in some criminal
activities let's say and then they
imagine that that he kills somebody in a
in a drug bust or something like you
know in a drug deal gone bad
well that's in essential so we're gonna
change the crime we're gonna make it you
kill somebody who's witnessed some
embezzlement that he's
shouldn't make any difference if you
thought that the mr. puppet in the first
instance wasn't responsible and
shouldn't be held responsible and that
this shouldn't change now I want to
change just one more thing they keep
talking about mr. puppet okay that's a
nice vivid name but it's just a name
shouldn't make any difference I'm going
to change it
let's call mr. puppet Oh captain
autonomy okay so now captain autonomy is
caused by an indifferent environment to
enter on a trajectory where becomes
likely that he is going to commit some
antisocial behavior and now the question
is whether he should be held responsible
well I think captain autonomy why
shouldn't he be held responsible let me
flesh it out a little bit more let's
suppose a captain autonomy is a Harvard
graduate who goes to work at Lehman
Brothers and sees a clever way of
embezzling a few million dollars and has
pulled off his his white-collar crime
when he discovers a person who has about
to expose him and he lures him to the
edge of the balcony and the horizon
pushes him off and he falls to his death
now that's my case now are we so clear
that captain autonomy is is not
responsible for his deed it seems to me
that I've drained the example of most of
the wolf that provided the intuitions
I'm not saying that my retelling of it
shows that he is responsible I'm just
pointing out that those details which
presumably are ad-lib and you shouldn't
they shouldn't make a difference they
make a huge difference in to how we
think about this person and whether or
not to hold and respond